il ya un bonsoir à tous j'espère que
vous passez un bon moment c'est un peu
difficile toujours pour quelqu'un de
passer après une présentation aussi
intéressante que juste avant donc merci
beaucoup pour la plantation précédent et
je vais peut-être faire un petit lien
aussi pour expliquer bah ouais le stress
les choix ce sont des choses qui sont
importantes et c'est un petit peu là
dessus que je veux que je veut axer les
choses vous parlez plus personnellement
aux étudiants mais je pense que au
travers de mon parcours et de ce que je
voudrais vous transmettre comme message
il ya peut-être des échos qui vont se
faire et des réflexions
en tout cas j'espère alors ce qui est
intéressant c'est que dans notre société
bah oui on est confronté à des choix en
permanence des choses on doit avoir une
place dans la société on doit jouer un
rôle
on doit cotiser on doit aller en
retraite on a plein plein plein de
passage dans la vie toutefois tout ça ça
arrive bien bien après qu'on ait fait
peut-être des choix peut-être anodin en
primaire au collège au lycée dans les
études supérieures et c'est tout
simplement en fait la question que je
veux un peu où la problématique que je
veux évoquer avec vous c'est le rôle des
études et delà du savoir et de la
connaissance dans la construction de nos
individus pour justement participé à la
cohérence de notre société future et
comme couche and l'a dit donc je
remercie de m'avoir présenter ben moi
potentiellement j'enseigne dans
l'enseignement supérieur je suis
j'estime être un enseignant chercheur
mais concrètement mon coeur de métier
c'est de comprendre les choses de les
expliquer et de transmettre un savoir et
donc j'ai pas de support vidéo pour pour
ma présentation par contre je n'ai qu'un
objet trouvé peut-être qui était
intéressant qu'il est il anodin mais je
pense que vous savez tous que c'est ça
un crayon un crayon pour écrire sur sur
un tableau alors ça c'est peut-être
anodin pour vous mais ça ça a été mon
gros traumatisme pendant beaucoup
beaucoup d'années au collège par exemple
dès qu'on appelait pour aller au tableau
alors la tête baissée je faisais
toujours tomber ma trousse je sais pas
si vous avez déjà utilisé cette
technique mais moi personnellement dès
qu'un prof me regarde et je faisais
tomber ma trousse et je cherchais par
terre
et le tableau c'est stressant c'est
traumatisant puis ça peut vous bloquez
et maintenant ce qui est paradoxal c'est
que des gens m'appellent monsieur le
professeur docteur comment allez vous je
suis pas différent j'estime entre avant
et maintenant et donc pour vous
expliquer ça je voudrais retracer
peut-être un peu mon histoire c'est un
exercice que j'ai jamais fait j'ai
beaucoup pensé mais je c'est vrai que
les jamais partagé donc j'espère que ça
vous intéressera alors pour cette
histoire va on va remonter un peu le
temps on va remonter en 1998 en juin 98
m pour être pour être exact alors c'est
à peu près au moment où l'équipe de
france de foot atteignait les quarts de
finale de la coupe du monde
moi j'étais confronté un autre dilemme
j'ai reçu une lettre
c'était la fin du collège j'étais
j'avais 17 ans et j'étais encore en
troisième et donc c'est la fin du
collège et là se pose un problème
vous recevez une lettre d'un lycée et la
lys et il vous dit désolé mais on veut
pas de vous donc qu'est ce qu'on fait
dans ce cas là et bah on fait appel à la
famille on va voir les profs principaux
on discute on essaie de trouver des
solutions et donc parmi les solutions
qui sont proposées à moi concrètement on
m'a proposé quelque chose j'avais
entendu parler mais je savais pas bien
ce que c'est et on va proposer un bep
georges pas peut-être qu'il y en a
certains qui connaissent pas ça existe
encore mais plus vraiment sous le même
format
il ya d'ailleurs beaucoup beaucoup de
choses qui ont évolué depuis depuis mai
on va dire mais mes études alors un bepc
un brevet d'enseignement professionnel
concrètement quand moi je suis rentré
dans ce dans cette formation là de la
part de certains de mes amis mon
entourage c'était bienvenue dans la voie
de garage
donc ça fait toujours un peu bizarre et
de se dire bah qu'est ce que qu'est ce
que je vais faire avec ça et plus
précisément donc j'ai fait un bep en ce
que s'appelait à l'époque métiers du
secrétariat et de la comptabilité
donc pour travailler dans des métiers de
service par exemple
dans n'importe quelle entreprise un
diplôme en deux ans avant le bac mais
bah voilà et s'arrêtent normalement ça
s'arrête là mais quand je suis rentré
dans ce à dire dans cette formation il
ya une sorte de déclic à une réflexion
de se dire bah c'est dommage et mes amis
vont au lycée moi j'y suis pas vraiment
ils continuent ils ont l'air de
s'épanouir et puis moi on fait faire des
choses pas vraiment gratifiant donc j'ai
commencé année de manière anecdotique on
va dire à lire à regarder dans des
ouvrages et puis même tour être un petit
peu plus précis quelqu'un m'a donné un
livre de codage joseph parle peut-être à
certains d'entre vous ont rien rien
d'exceptionnel on m'a fait lire des
livres de html c'était le début on va
dire d'internet qui arrivait et puis je
trouvais ça original du maintien alors
qu'on va commencer à regarder
et puis de fil en aiguille et ben ce qui
s'est passé c'est que bastien c'est
intéressant d'apprendre des choses c'est
intéressant de comprendre surtout à quoi
servent les choses que j'apprends et de
les appliquer et là bas mais le déclic
va commencer à se faire et puis pendant
mon bep je me suis dit bon bah qu'est ce
que je veux faire plus tard je veux un
bac ça
voilà c'est clair je veux un bac
malheureusement à l'époque le bac 10
général c'était plus possible il n'y
avait pas forcément de commandes de
passerelles qui était possible et donc
ce n'était pas possible
donc ce que ce que j'ai fait j'ai eu mon
bep sépara très très compliqué hein mais
bon faut quand même travailler un petit
peu et tout en essayant de lire
d'apprendre des choses de m'épanouir par
différentes méthodes et puis surtout
pour essayer de faire un dossier pour
entrer en ce qu'on appelle première
d'adaptation c'est pareil c'est des
choses qui n'existent plus ou moins
encore mais qui ont plus ou moins
peut-être un peu disparu avec des
refontes administratives et cette
première d'adaptation c'est quoi c'est à
dire à des élèves vont vous venez d'un
milieu qui est pas forcément un niveau
éducatif très élevé mais on va vous
proposer des heures en plus c'est du
soutien scolaire et puisque vous allez
essayer de faire c'est de passer un bac
technologique
alors donc moi je me suis inscrit dans
un lycée dans les côtes d'armor un petit
lycée
dans un petit village mais très très
sympathique et puis on en a inscrit dans
ce qu'on appelle à l'époque un
baccalauréat est était alors est cet été
ça n'existe plus pareil c'est encore
changer ça c'était les sciences et
techniques du tertiaire pour travailler
potentiellement dans le commerce un peu
la comptabilité pareil secrétariat la
bureautique etc
donc ça c'est un bac technologique
maintenant ça n'existe plus
l'appellation cstm j'ai si je dis pas de
bêtises ces sciences du tertiaire du
management et de la gestion
on adore 1 modifié comme ça les les
comment les titres mais en gros c'est
toujours un peu la même chose qui est
qui est évoqué et avec ce bac
technologique l'avantagent c'est que
j'avais une possibilité
c'était que ce bac m'autorisait à
accéder à un milieu qui me faisait rêver
depuis mai des années que je croyait
inaccessible
c'est tout simplement l'université ce
que pour rappel le bac en fait et ba
c'est le premier diplôme universitaire
et c'est ce qui permet de valider les
connaissances des acquis pour pouvoir
justement rentrer dans ce milieu
universitaire alors soit baigner je sais
pas - dans des séries des films les
choses comme ça à l'université c'était
un mythe et je voulais à tout prix
vraiment à tout prix rentrer on a un
petit peu découragé on a montré des
choses a dit mme banon alain bas que
pour rentrer à l'université tu viens de
là cet été tu viens de bep c'est pas
forcément une bonne chose mais le mieux
serait plutôt que tu ailles en bts ou
potentiellement dans des dut des
formations universitaires mais dans les
iut
pourquoi pas et puis comme je vous avais
expliqué je m'intéressais un petit peu à
l'informatique mais sans être un
professionnel du bâtiment je vais tenter
un iut d'informatique et puis là bas ça
continue en fait
et puis je reçois un jour une lettre mon
bac donc j'avais pas encore les
résultats et je reçois une lettre d'un
iut qui me disent merci de nous avoir
contacter votre cv très intéressant mais
en gros vous venez d'un bep donc c'est
pas la peine de venir chez nous et là
bas encore une douche froide
et puis encore un peu une démobilisation
donc c'est pour ça quand on parle de
choix de deux problématiques est-ce que
je suis à la hauteur est ce que je suis
pertinent pour cette société
c'est vrai que c'est un peu douloureux
toujours de recevoir ces lettres qui
vous explique pourquoi
vous n'êtes pas adapté à quelque chose
et là bas mon choix était clair
maintenant je me pose plus de questions
je fais plus de dossiers j'essaye plus
de dire à des gens pourquoi je pourrais
être pertinent pour travailler avec eux
ou être en formation avec eux c'est
simple je rentre à l'université mon bac
me donnant l'autorisation je me suis
inscrit et puis je suis rentrée donc à
l'université de sciences économiques de
rennes pour pour commencer et là ça a
été quand même dur ça a été très très
dur avant il y avait un autre diplôme
s'appelait le dogue
donc j'ai commencé avec ce diplôme là
c'était le bac +2 en fait
et puis bah ouais ça a été dur c'était
dur mais au cours de ceux de cette
formation rencontrer des enseignants
rentrer des gens du monde professionnel
qui vous explique en fait à quoi ça sert
l'épanouissement intellectuel
à quoi ça sert d'avoir de la
connaissance comment on peut l'utiliser
et surtout comment on peut l'appliquer
au monde de la société alors là pour le
moment c'était plus un aspect vraiment
culturel je n'avais pas d'autre objectif
que ça c'était juste d'atteindre chaque
année je passe un semestre
je passe une année et je continue et
puis bah pour le moment j'ai pas
vraiment de métier en tête j'ai rien de
vraiment concret comme projet
professionnel
par contre ce que j'essayais de faire
des stages de découverte de
l'environnement d'entreprise ou deux
il y eu plus ou moins professionnels
pour essayer de réfléchir
qu'est ce que je pourrais faire et
surtout qu'est ce qui pourrai m'épanouir
plus tard donc je me suis un petit peu
spécialisé en comptabilité finance audit
financier c'est une chose que je
trouvais intéressante et puis en plus il
y avait plutôt que cela est plutôt un
secteur qui était porteur en terme de
travail
bon ben on va on va aller là dedans donc
je réussis à voir mon deug alors les
licences j'ai réussi à l'avoir mais un
petit peu plus dur je suis passé par la
repêche j'ai eu beaucoup plus de
difficultés on va dire à remonter un
niveau plutôt scientifique mathématique
mais ça va j'ai réussi je suis mes
examens ça s'est bien passé et donc
après ma licence à rennes je suis parti
à nantes à l'université de nantes en
gestion et management des entreprises
et puis bah nouvel environnement dont
l'un des intellectuels et puis
relationnel aussi nouveaux enseignants
nouvelle vision des choses on s'épanouit
on acquiert de la connaissance on
acquiert du savoir et on construit petit
à petit son projet arrive les partielle
de leurs têtes même pas de faim de fin
d'année c'était de milieu de semaine on
était au mois de début janvier on en
six pour être pour être exact et puis là
une réflexion qui m'arrive une question
qui se pose cependant un examen où ça se
passait très très bien il n'y avait pas
de souci j'avais pas de blanc j'étais
content de ce que j'étais en train de
faire
mais là c'est de se dire mais je suis en
train de faire des études est en train
de faire des choses j'apprends du savoir
et de la connaissance
je suis en train de l'appliquer pour un
examen mais en gros cet examen
c'est ce que je vais faire pendant les
quarante prochaines années de ma vie est
là il ya eu comme une grosse baffe que
je me suis pris au sens images et je
suis sorti de cet amphi j'ai passé tous
mes examens mais à la fin de l'année
j'ai dit à mes enseignants bombe à ce
que je vais faire non c'est je vais pas
continuer la spécialisation après en
master 2 il faut que je trouve quelque
chose d'autre et en cherchant en fait je
me suis rendu compte que les livres la
connaissance le savoir c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui me met vraiment une
permettait de m'épanouir bas peut-être
que le métier de chercheur dans ce cas
d'enseignants peut être intéressant et à
partir de ce moment là j'ai plus ou
moins essayer de construire d'un projet
est hélas match pareil j'ai recommencé
un peu cette vision des choses qui me
faisait peur c'est à dire de faire des
candidatures et j'ai candidaté en fait à
différentes universités pour entrer
anciennement ce qui s'appelait un dea et
postuler après une thèse de doctorat
donc j'ai été pris dans plusieurs
universités puis mon choix s'est porté
pour la ville de brest comme ça a été
dit l'implantation je suis breton mais
je me suis déplacé à dans plusieurs
régions mais bon là je voulais rester un
peu en bretagne et je suis revenu à
brest et puis de la l'épanouissement on
va dire sur des applications sur de la
science surtout sur des domaines de
professionnalisation qui était vraiment
concret l'application de recherche de
sciences au chat à des domaines
d'activité professionnelle et surtout
qu'ils pouvaient être utiles à la
société
aussi un film que ce soit donc j'ai
décidé de
j'ai décidé j'ai construit et on m'a
beaucoup aidé pour ça aussi
et bien tout simplement une thèse de
doctorat et puis un directeur a été
intéressée a été intéressé par mon père
mon sujet donc j'étais basé ici pour
ceux qui connaissent à l'université de
bretagne occidentale mais plus
précisément à l'institut universitaire
européen de la mer juste à côté c'est à
cent mètres d'ici un petit bâtiment
laquelle collet l'ifremer et puis mon
directeur de thèse lui il était de
l'école d'économie de toulouse
donc j'ai pu comme ça profiter de
plusieurs approches différentes de
plusieurs mentors plusieurs applications
et tout ça s'est construit au fur et à
mesure des années au fur et à mesure des
des commandes des expériences on va dire
j'ai beaucoup voyagé grâce à cette thèse
et puis après bail arrivait la fin au
petit à petit de la thèse est de se dire
mais après la thèse qu'est ce qu'on fait
donc c'est vrai qu'on saignant
chercheurs c'est intéressant j'aime
beaucoup j'aime beaucoup cette vision
des choses je dis c'est peut-être trop
limités par rapport à un peu la vision
que j'ai l'organisation que j'ai le mode
de travail que j'ai donc ce que j'ai
décidé de faire c'est en 2010 pendant
que j'étais encore étudiant c'est de
créer ma société
eh ben je me suis lancé potentiellement
qu'un entrepreneur j'ai potentiellement
essayer de vendre et de proposer mes
services
ça a été très très très difficile au
départ mais est encore sous le statut
d'étudiant bas c'est vrai que j'avais
quand même des avantages des protections
en gros cinq ans cinq à six ans il m'a
fallu pour vraiment créer le réseau
cette société et puis les services que
je voulais proposer et bah maintenant on
est en 2018
et avec un peu de recul avec un peu plus
de réflexion
j'estime que je suis épanoui dans la vie
j'ai plus d'expérience à venir devant
moi que derrière moi donc j'ai encore
beaucoup beaucoup de choses à apprendre
et à corriger mais concrètement je me
sens maintenant utile dans la société et
surtout je trouve et j'espère avoir ma
place dans la société
pour ça que ça résonne à mes oreilles ce
qui est et ce qui est évoqué avant le
traumatisme potentiellement peut-être
des études de la surcharge du travail de
du risque parce qu'en fait les études
c'est quoi c'est qu'un pari sur l'avenir
si on regarde on parie quelque chose
mais on sait pas du tout ce que ça va
faire
la société évolue vous travaillerez je
pense pas les 40 prochaines années dans
votre secteur d'activité ou dans votre
métier dédiée ou dans une entreprise
dédiée il ya beaucoup de choses qui vont
évoluer
mais concrètement vous allez participer
aussi
vous en tant que futur en tant
qu'étudiant actuelle mais futurs acteurs
de la société professionnelle et qui
construisent le futur tout simplement à
proposer vos connaissances cumulé des
connaissances et par quelque moyen que
ce soit si vous intervenez dans des
universités ou des écoles plus tard si
vous êtes maître d'apprentissage plus
tard vous interviendrez dans ce
processus de diffusion du savoir et de
la connaissance
et c'est à ce sens en fait le la
philosophie que j'ai en fait dans ma
prime une prestation de service et le
rôle que je pense en vous j'espère avoir
en tout cas eh ben c'est de fournir tout
simplement de la collecte d'informations
de la collecte de connaissances et puis
de la transmission de connaissances
donc en fait pour si je devais résumer
les choses il ya un adage auquel je
m'accroche beaucoup qui m'a toujours on
va dire servi au travers de mes études
bah quoi qu'il arrive ainsi que jamais
de jamais arrêté même si on prend si on
prend on va dire des baffes
parce que des deux des tôles dans les
facs j'en ai pris beaucoup donc s'aimer
toujours essayer de se relever d'aller
toujours de l'avant même si vous prenez
des mauvaises notes
c'est pas grave on continue le principal
c'est que j'ai appris des choses et que
je peux les utiliser
et puis d'un autre côté c'est que en
fait je pense qu'on est tous
perpétuellement des éternels étudiants
en fait on se lasse de tout sauf d'une
chose et cette phrase elle est pas de
moi c'est qu'on se lasse de tout sauf
d'une chose c'est d'apprendre et on est
des perpétuelles étudiants tout au cours
tout au long de notre vie concrète et
puis la société nous montrera dans son
évolution
je termine cette cette explication de ma
vie on va dire ma courte vie d'étudiant
et professionnels j'espère ne pas avoir
choqué certains de mes étudiants que je
vais retrouver lundi matin à 9 heures
peut-être ne pas avoir peut-être perdu
sur le piédestal de votre de ce que je
suis je suis docteur mais j'ai aussi un
bep donc en fait j'ai concrètement dans
la société française j'ai les deux
diplômes les plus éloignés qui existe et
je vous assure que les deux eh bien ils
sont très très utiles tous les jours je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]